i didn't actually want to do this
but here we are hey what is up guys
mkbhd here and the iphone 6s came out a
couple weeks ago you've probably already
seen the reviews it's out there one of
the biggest changes from the iphone 6 to
the new iphone 6s is the updated specs
including the new a9 chip so the a9 chip
isn't actually manufactured by apple
apple is not a manufacturing company but
it's essentially designed by them and
then contracted out to be built by a
manufacturer and then put in the new
iphone so this year for the iphone 6s
there were actually two companies
contracted to make the a9 chip in the
new phone tsmc and samsung yes samsung
one of apple's biggest enemies builds
the processor in the new iphone so on
the outside there's no actual way to
know which one of those two guys built
the a9 chip in your iphone before you
buy it it'll just be a random selection
essentially and there's also no official
reason given why there are two
manufacturers to such a major component
but it's probably volume tsmc couldn't
crank out 13 million of these chips by
themselves samsung couldn't crank out 13
million of these ships by themselves so
apple contracted both of them and they
both make the a9 ship and they both get
put into the iphone so the only way to
know which version of the a9 chip you
have in your iphone is to check after
you buy it so there's an app called
lyrium in the app store it's free and
i'll link it below that like button and
on the about screen it will tell you
what model of the cpu you have in the
iphone 6s it's the n71map for the tsmc
built a9 chip and the n71ap for the
samsung built a9 and you can see there's
also a difference between the chips and
the 6s plus so here's the thing the tsmc
built a9 and the samsung built a9 aren't
exactly the same i don't know why you'd
think they would be identical but the
tsmc built a9 chip is slightly bigger
than the samsung one coming in at 104.5
millimeters squared while the samsung
one is a slightly smaller 96 millimeter
square on an soc like this you can kind
of think of chip size like sensor size
on a camera meaning bigger usually
enables better performance and
efficiency the bigger chip on the tsmc
a9 is built on a 16 nanometer
construction as opposed to the 14
nanometer samsung chip so once people
figured out that there could legit be
one of two different sized a9 chips in
your iphone naturally people began to
test to see if there's a legit
difference in performance and battery
life between the two chips naturally we
expect the larger tsmc built chip to do
better at both
and it does someone found out that on
the geekbench battery test the tsmc
phone lasts up to 20 to 30 percent
longer than the samsung built one cue
all the articles i guess we got
ourselves another gate well it turns out
the geekbench test is essentially the
worst case scenario if you're a cpu and
it's kind of hard to translate that test
into real world usage the geekbench test
is basically just maxing out the cpu at
a hundred percent and running it until
the battery's dead and measuring how
long that took real world behavior
doesn't do this though even with a whole
lot of heavy use you're constantly
cycling between a whole bunch of
different performance levels whether
you're gaming or web browsing or
multitasking with apps or texting or at
sleep or whatever it's doing so at full
max load the tsmc chip being a little
bit bigger is definitely an advantage
but at every other performance level
that's not max load the difference is
almost nothing and that's exactly what
apple will tell you that other tests
show maybe two to three percent
difference at worst my buddy austin
showed in his video a tsmc and samsung
iphone running side by side playing an
hour-long youtube video obviously you're
not maxing out power or anything and
when it was over the tsmc chip burned 14
and the samsung 15 another friend john
over at tld tried a 30 minute time lapse
with both phones at the end the tsmc
phone was at 89 percent and the samsung
at 84. and rs technica did a bunch of
tests with identical iphones one with
each chip with the displays calibrated
at the same brightness and everything
and found minimal differences across the
board with battery life tests again the
tsmc phone did better in almost every
category thanks to the slightly bigger
chip but very slightly and even all
these are still benchmarking apps that
are trying to synthetically simulate
real world usage but by the time you get
your phone and install all your apps and
get to using it in your mix of high
performance versus low performance tasks
you probably won't even notice the
difference at all so obviously it would
have been nice to have that nice big
tsmc built a9 chip in every iphone but
it's not a huge deal if you get a
samsung one like i did if you're not
maxing out your phone all the time like
the geekbench test what's funny is
apple's actually used multiple
manufacturers for other parts in the
iphone before they do this all the time
for stuff like the ram and the flash
storage so i guess it's not really
unusual although it is unusual for them
to be different sizes and not identical
but i guess apple's answer to all this
is a loosely paraphrased
close enough so what do you guys think
is chip gate a big deal to you or not i
know i'm a heavy user and yes i had the
samsung chip in my iphone for my review
and i was happy with the battery life so
it wasn't a big deal to me but i feel
like if we need to start another gate
which do we really but if we do it
should be about something that's
actually terrible like the way this
mouse charges anyway thank you guys for
watching this one feel free to share
this video with anyone you think might
be interested in this whole iphone ship
gate thing and if you hit that subscribe
button below you'll be among the first
to see new videos like this when they
come out again thanks for watching and
i'll talk to you guys in the next one
peace